regardez cette photo cyril s'est
personnellement tous que tout ce que
j'adore un écran d'ordinateur avec rien
dessus une salle d'une totale sobriété
et c'est tout ce que nous et demi des
tests une les mains ouvertes pour une
prière qui ne s'adresse qu'aux savoir
une main ouverte complètement athée et
un homme qui regarde du haut vers le bas
et qui regarde ses élèves un regard qui
pétille d'intelligence et de modestie
il est habillé de manière très modeste
en noir les hussards noirs de la
république
et cet homme là et j'espère que ça aura
de la valeur pour tous les élèves
maintenant de france cet homme là est
mort non pas parce qu'il a utilisé son
droit au blasphème mais parce qu'il a
fait un cours théorique sur ce que
voulait dire le blasphème donc voyez à
quel point on est monté d'un degré
extrême et je crois que je veux pas
parler à sa place ça serait obscène mais
ce qu'il aurait fait plaisir ce soir
c'est peut-être parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des enseignants je pense que
cet homme aurait adoré qu'on parle tous
des élèves de france de tous ceux qui
vont retourner dans les lycées dans les
collèges en se disant la personne qui
est en train de m'apprendre l'histoire
de france est en danger de mort parce
qu'elle est en train de le faire moi
j'ai été plus que bouleversés par cette
histoire j'ai été déracinés l'école est
le lieu que j'ai préféré de toute ma vie
et j'en ai pas honte et je crois que je
vais rejoindre geoffrey lejeune sur un
point la vie quelque chose de très fins
de très subtil tout à l'heure qui est
difficile à entendre
la première chose c'est que ce qui me
gêne dans le droit au blasphème et dans
le blasphème en tant que tel c'est que
il ne l'est pas confondu et que la
liberté expression et qu'on a
l'impression à l'utiliser sans cesse
qu'on établit un dialogue entre celui
qui utilise le blasphème de manière
péremptoire et obsessionnelle et celui
qui est censé être heurtée et vexée par
le blasphème canton blasphème toute la
journée
qu'on le veuille ou non on rentre dans
un dialogue et la deuxième chose où je
voudrais à la fois rejoindre karim et
m'ont éloigné simultanément c'est qu' il
ne faut pas imaginer qu'elle est gentil
musulmans tout ce qu'on aime les humilie
les musulmans pacifistes et qu'ils ont
raison d'être heureux avec leur religion
et les méchants c'est à dire les
islamistes ce qui m'inquiète c'est la
zone grise la zone de porosité dont on
ne parle jamais qui essentiellement fait
de musulmans qui jamais ne commettre un
attentat mais qui sont bien quand
tant qu'un attentat comète et là où je
me décide à reese en revanche
complètement de mon amie karine pour
lequel j'ai beaucoup d'amitié c'est que
à titre personnel et ça n'engage que moi
si je dirais que précisément parce que
les musulmans n'ont rien à voir avec
l'islamisme pour cette raison seuls qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'islamisme
j'aimerais les voir dehors j'aimerais
les voir défiler précisément parce
qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec ces actes
et qu'effectivement il y aurait un avant
après et je vais pas intellectualiser
des choses cyril pourquoi je leur
demandais tue personne parce que ça me
ferait du bien car il répondait oui je
suis choqué de ses deux sauts de cette
dernière proposition je voudrait les
voir défiler comme s'il n'était pas dans
la manifestation place de la république
il avait comme s'il fallait les rimes a
dit rien n'avait pas comme s'il fallait
les repérer avec un insigne quelconque
où je dirais un trait particulier les
musulmans sont parties de la communauté
nationale je n'ai jamais eu une bonne
fois pour toutes
est ce que j'ai dit en place d'un comité
national - cherian ils s'indignent ils
s'insurgent ils sont tristes ils sont
meurtris comme la communauté nationale
et karim chérif partie prenante de la
manifestation
mais effectivement si vous êtes dans une
démarche de comptabilité il y avait des
milliers de personnes ne nous gommons
mari pour des événements là mais
franchement ne nous font pas poser de
risque appétit évident
je crée le double insulte voilà jean
sassi télé pas 10 et musulmans à
s'indigner à manifester être meurtri
c'est lamentable ce que les rimes je
suis dans ce cas encore une fois dans
une manifestation je suis désolé et rien
avantage vous pouvez pas faire le tri tu
me prends ma - un musulman mais alain
natoli carré les juifs ou les athées il
parle d'eux
de comptabilité cirque il voudrait
laisser dire mais je crois que t'as pas
bien compris ce que j'ai dit que il y
avait une histoire de dicerna bilité que
je pourrai discerner dans la nation qui
est musulman qu'il n'est pas en gros
c'est au faciès que j'arriverai à
repérer qui est musulman je n'ai jamais
dit ça et comment alors si tu qu'il
n'était pas partial tation j'étais dans
la manifestation
suite aux crimes qui avaient commis
mohamed merah je peux dire de manière
complètement décomplexé que je n'ai vu
dans ces manifestations quasiment que
des juifs parce que hélas je ne jette
pas la pierre aux musulmans la plupart
des français musulmans et nantes ou non
se disait c'est un truc qui n'arrive
qu'aux juifs mais quand on commence à
s'en prendre aux juifs dans une nation
il faut savoir passer leurs habitudes
jansch parce que les associations juives
et et la gelée irina les autres
n'étaient pas là mais qui arrive et ses
mystères et demi c'est jeudi et je te le
dis en face karim les autres n'étaient
c'était pas des réactions outrées en
permanence aux fêtes sont sont assez
fatigantes
la vérité c'est que moi je pense qu'il y
en a raison et quand il parle de
rénovateur atteindre grâce et moi je
vous dis que je vais t'expliquer quand
il parle de zones grises quand il dit
ces gens dont on n'arrive pas à
discerner quelle et lequel l opinion sur
le sujet et dont on se dit qu'ils ne
passeront évidemment jamais à l'acte il
y en a plein mais qui se réjouissent de
l'attentât ça existe en france on est
d'accord
bon tu dis tu nous explique qu'il ya des
musulmans qui vont manifester contre les
attentats ouais mais évidemment c'est le
cas à benoît m'a jamais dit l'inversé
quoi quitter ce pays je te donne un
exemple est ce que tu es d'accord pour
dire que quand il ya la minute de
silence après charlie hebdo a été sifflé
dans des collèges de banlieue
ça n'était que dans des collèges de
banlieue où il y avait des classes de
laver des élèves musulmans à ce que tu
es d'accord pour dire ça oui mais si tu
veux me fait d'ailleurs écho d'un
comportement inacceptable quand même
bande décoller pour mieux gérer moi
c'est oui à ce que ces comportements
inacceptables sur le fait d'une majorité
la réponse est non
l'argument gens n'arrivant karine
vergniol parler très longtemps un
argument route lorsqu'il ya eu une
marche contre l'islamophobie
on les voyait les musulmans en tant que
tel et j'aimerais simplement que sans
qu'on les voit en tant que tel parce que
je ne voudrais pas que eux seuls soit
dans cette manifestation
ce qu'on a vu par exemple dans la marche
contre limite slam aux phobies ou là on
les a bien reconnu ils se sont faits en
reconnaître alors que moi je leur
demande pas d'être discernable
j'aimerais que cela par exemple contient
un attentat fasse la même chose que
lorsqu'ils descendent pour compte contre
le laisse aller et c'est là que mon
raisonnement c'est ça qui est ça que mon
raisonnement tapenade noire
comment savez-vous qu'il n'était pas là
la marche je vais vous répondre ça c'est
ce que j'avais bien sûr parce que je
savais ils veulent nous coincer là
dessus ça incroyable d'un détecteur non
non non non bien sûr que non
c'est justement parce que ça n'a rien à
voir que j'aimerais qu'il sorte et s'ils
savaient avoir évidemment on compense
avec et moi j'ai à tanger et tétouan
tout j'ai vu des films a parlé notamment
celui de levallois perret je suis désolé
de celui de barbe est alors oui mais
voilà alors qu'il est par ces débris il
a pas mis à la porte en attaque comme ça
mais laxiste et désolé vous pouvez
regarder depuis vendredi je regarde les
plateaux télé et j'ai vu beaucoup de
gens musulmans français musulmans qui
ont dit cette scandaleuse et je veux pas
qu'on amalgame j'ai produit ici alors je
dis qu'il faut qu'ils chantent bien sûr
la course aux pv alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait se justifie plus lente mais
n'ont même pas d'appareil à détection
mais non ça serait ok ça me tue atteint
non mais moi je vais te dire
concrètement parce que j'ai là au bout
d'un moment je peux pas laisser je suis
pas très intelligent mais me faire
insulter c'est pas possible non plus le
pain et je dis simplement et ça n'aura
échappé à personne je vais t'expliquer
en mieux en plus c'est simple un plus
jeune en jouant mieux c'est un peu
bébête non on endure à voir si ce moment
comme les professeurs je pars du
principe que quand quelqu'un comprend
pas c'est moi qui m'exprime allait pas
l'interlocuteur québec mais tu pense
aussi mais là on est d'accord
non mais moi je pars du principe que ça
vient c'est de me fallait aller ombre
jeu j'ai remarqué et si je me trompe
je veux bien faire allégeance à la
vérité du moment que ça la vérité j'ai
remarqué que lorsqu'il ya un attentat ce
sont toujours les mêmes imams d'ailleurs
extrêmement dignes et courageuses convoi
je demande juste en voir d'autres des
nouveaux des visages 9
on en a vu un c'est toujours les trois
nommées car ici la question la question
après dilution min appelé georges et des
baises l'a alors rachetée marino et et
place de république à laquelle nous
réserver les autres disent
j'étais en colère
eric naulleau genre étendue n'en
déplaise à mme meriem zéribi j'ai
entendu le recteur de la grande mosquée
de paris telle qu'une institution pour
laquelle j'ai plus grand à dire qu'il y
avait une responsabilité en effet
spécifique des musulmans qu'ils
voulaient que des musulmans à la
traduisent un petit peu plus leurs états
d'âme parce que dans leur immense
majorité évidemment ils sont aussi
horrifiés que n'importe quel autre
citoyen français donc il ya quand même
il n'est pas moins musulmans que toi ma
faim bon ben voilà il a sa voix compte
donc il dit en effet que dans des
périodes de crise comme ça il est bon
que les musulmans en tant que tel en
tant que davantage entendaient répandre
alors moi je vais vous dire il ya deux
choses d'abord il faut qu'on sorte un
peu de la schizophrénie à la française
il prétend ou leur lutter contre le
séparatisme le communautarisme et
atteindre qu'une communauté un part
actif huszti la communauté musulmane
s'est insurgé s'indigne puisque
désormais on en a besoin et c'est de
finir car il sait que les arguments vous
dérange mes employés vont lutter contre
le communautarisme et vouloir
effectivement le généré l'incarner et
qui sont représentées pour s'indigner du
jeu que rien ne change je veux plus rien
contre totalement moi je fais en sorte
que l'école que les français de
confession musulmane fasse partie la
communauté nationale mais ils le font
c'est bien sûr car le tri c'est à dire
entre les uns et les autres ont des
visions religieuses
moi je veux cette france là vous voulez
autre chose non vous voulez effectuer
yolain succession d'eric insultants sur
ton coin sur le président de leurs
erreurs de la mosquée de paris
mais la grande mosquée temps et qui a
dit qui a dit que les membres d'une
communauté religieuse devait s'abstenir
de faire en leur sein elle travaille
jamais de dire de réflexion vers le
savoir vers la lumière
pour sortir des espaces obscurantistes
qui existe qui a dit que les catholiques
ne devait pas faire un travail pour
démontrer que la religion catholique
mais n'est pas porteur on est d'accord
syndrome de la pédophilie
elle m'a dit qu'il fallait pas faire un
travail sur cette personne car le sang
il faut le faire mais ce travail là
c'est sans doute la confusion
c'est un travail de la nation entière
l'enseignant paix à son âme est
effectivement durée tu veux que rien ne
change que ça je pense pas du tout mais
sagan qu'on a prétendu les musulmans au
sein de la communauté musulmane doivent
être attentif vigilant pour
effectivement que faire en sorte que des
sectes qui utilisent bien il vous arrive
de pourra présenter en s'estimant
polluer c'est une communauté unie et
qu'on n'a pas entendu la communauté
nationale dans son ensemble doit se
serrer de colère à corte côte à côte et
faire unités jeu le centre ce fléau